[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
-Welcome to Silicon Valley.
I'm looking for the
next big invention.
-And I'm here to kick
your ass into shape.
I am going to conquer the world!
This is your life!
-We make dreams a reality.
-In the end, it could
be worth bazillions.
-A million dollars in revenue!
[CHEERING]
-"Bazillion Dollar Club."
The series premiere Tuesday,
September 22 at 10:00 on Syfy.
[END PLAYBACK]
DANA HAN-KLEIN: Hi, everyone.
Welcome to "Talks at Google."
My name is Dana Han-Klein.
And today, it is my
pleasure to welcome
Dave McClure from 500
Startups and Brady Forrest
from Highway1.
Let's give them a
round of applause.
[CHEERS]
[APPLAUSE]
Guys, welcome to Google.
Do you mind telling us a
little bit about yourselves,
and how have you
found yourselves
as sort of members of the
Bazillion Dollar Club?
BRADY FORREST: I don't
think either of us
are quite bazillionaires yet.
DAVE MCCLURE: Yeah,
still working on it.
I started off as a small
boy in a farm town.
Grew up on the East Coast--
West Virginia and Maryland.
Went to Hopkins.
Kind of came out to California
as a geek and programmer
in '89, which seems like
such a long time ago now.
But variously had
different roles
here in the valley--
programmer, entrepreneur.
Worked at Paypal doing
some marketing for awhile.
Angel Investor, and then
eventually venture capitalist,
I guess.
Yeah.
Sort of.
BRADY FORREST: I
grew up in Jersey.
Went to RPI, engineering.
Did inventory control
systems for awhile.
DAVE MCCLURE: Fascinating.
BRADY FORREST: I know.
It was amazing.
Then consumer software,
then O'Reilly Media,
where I started Ignite
and then ended up
running a hardware accelerator.
And luckily, Dave and I
had met back in 2005, back
when I was still at Microsoft,
and you were at Simply Hired.
And we just stayed in
touch over the years.
And about two years
ago, Dave was like, hey,
I'm thinking about
doing a TV show.
But would you-- they also
want hardware in this.
Do you want to get involved?
DAVE MCCLURE:
Basically, I was trying
to work my way into a TV show,
but I needed somebody sexier
than--
[LAUGHTER]
DAVE MCCLURE: [INAUDIBLE]
was doing hardware.
DANA HAN-KLEIN: To amplify
the sexy, you know.
DAVE MCCLURE: Yeah.
Well, you know, look.
With this package,
I mean, come on.
But yeah, I guess--
it took a while.
Eventually, we
kind of got there.
BRADY FORREST: And now Highway1
is a hardware accelerator
in San Francisco, and our fifth
batch started two weeks ago.
DAVE MCCLURE: And I guess 500
Startups is an accelerator.
Whoa!
DANA HAN-KLEIN: Oh, no!
DAVE MCCLURE: I'm
breaking my shit.
And seed fund.
And we're mostly in San
Francisco and Mountain View,
but also about 15 other
countries around the world.
DANA HAN-KLEIN: Great.
Can you walk us through
just a typical schedule
for an accelerator program.
DAVE MCCLURE: I guess it
varies by program, but probably
between three to six months.
Ours is usually
about four months
of kind of active involvement,
although there's maybe a month
on either side hazing people
coming in and kicking them
out on the way out.
BRADY FORREST: Yeah.
They don't like to leave.
The free office space--
DAVE MCCLURE: We
give them money,
and they just hang around.
BRADY FORREST: --and the snacks,
and in our case, the shop.
DANA HAN-KLEIN: Yeah.
We know nothing about that here.
BRADY FORREST: I've heard
about the Google 15.
DANA HAN-KLEIN: It's the 20.
The Google 20.
Yeah, 15 was college.
But could you talk to us
a little bit, just about
for those who don't
necessarily know
what it's like to be in an
accelerated program, kind
of the things that are involved
for the sort of mentees,
or the applicants, and what they
can expect to gain out of it,
and what you guys are going
to provide as mentors.
BRADY FORREST: Well,
each accelerator program
has a different specialty.
Ours, in particular,
focuses on hardware.
So we have 1,000 square
feet of shop space.
I've got mechanical engineers,
electrical engineer, a shop
tech, a designer, all
of whom specialize
in helping to move
companies with a prototype
forward until it
becomes a product.
At the same time,
we work with them
trying to figure out, if
they're consumer, what
their crowdfunding strategy is,
what their revenue model looks
like, how they can
actually afford
to manufacture the product.
Along the way, we also help
them out with their pitch.
Because at the end of
the day, on your demo
today, you want to be
able to tell your story
and show your product.
DAVE MCCLURE: I think
there's a lot of stuff
that we try and help them with.
The primary thing is
we give them money.
We try and help them with
customer acquisition.
We try and help them
with additional funding.
But we do introduce them
to mentors along the way.
Most of our companies
are software
focused, whether that's
web or internet or mobile.
Most of them come in
with a functional product
and usually a small amount
of customers or revenue.
We hopefully try and help
them get to a larger amount
of customers and revenue.
DANA HAN-KLEIN: A
bazillion dollars.
DAVE MCCLURE: A
bazillion dollars!
Muah ha ha.
And most of this culminates in
a demo day with the companies
presenting their products to
a large room of-- hopefully
a large room of investors.
And if they're fortunate, some
of them raise a million bucks.
Some of them don't.
BRADY FORREST: And
kind of the difference
is, generally my teams are
trying to make one of something
by the end of the program.
So one of the teams,
Spin, from the show,
is trying to make a
centrifugal coffee machine.
And they've made a
couple of prototypes,
and they're trying to make
a final prototype that they
can then really demonstrate
that the product works
and is worth investing in.
DAVE MCCLURE: Right.
DANA HAN-KLEIN: And can
you guys talk a little bit
about, you know, you do
have different emphasis--
emphasisses, emphasi?
DAVE MCCLURE: Emphases.
DANA HAN-KLEIN: Emphases?
You know, in terms
of your backgrounds,
in terms of what you focus on.
But this show is kind
of bringing those
together a little bit.
And it's also-- you guys
tend, it seems like,
have different
mentor styles maybe?
DAVE MCCLURE: Really?
BRADY FORREST: No, no, no.
DAVE MCCLURE: We're
exactly the same person.
DANA HAN-KLEIN: What?
BRADY FORREST: We finish
each other's sentences.
DAVE MCCLURE: Exactly.
Um, yeah.
Maybe just a tiny--
DANA HAN-KLEIN: So what's
that collaborative process
kind of been like on this?
Or you can say no comment.
BRADY FORREST: Pretty seat
of the pants, actually.
We've been kind of figuring
it out as we go along.
But it's been interesting to
help each other's companies
out.
Because Dave has wisely
avoided hardware for years.
DAVE MCCLURE: One of the
companies in the show
is hardware-based out
of our program, which
has been great for them
to get access to Brady,
and [INAUDIBLE] and PCH.
BRADY FORREST: Yeah.
And this is bringing
me back to software,
which was my roots
for a long time,
especially working
with developers.
So I think we've
just been trading
off our complementary
skills here.
DAVE MCCLURE: But I
think there's probably
a set up as the odd couple of
the nerd kingdoms of sorts.
BRADY FORREST:
Yeah, you don't want
to read the pilot
for the second show.
DANA HAN-KLEIN: [INAUDIBLE].
I think maybe we do.
So like the Bay Area is pretty
immersed in the tech culture.
But are there some
kind of things
that you'd want an audience
who aren't necessarily
familiar with the
challenges of being
in this sort of environment
to know going into it?
DAVE MCCLURE: I mean, I
think the intent of the show
is to be entertaining, but also
to tell the story of what it's
like to be doing a
startup in the Bay Area,
and not to manufacture too
much of that story line.
I think we're really trying to
be somewhat authentic to what
people go through.
You don't really need to
create a lot of drama.
Startups have enough fail
by themselves that it's
pretty dramatic already.
Software companies raise money.
Startup founders break up.
Sometimes their shit works.
Sometimes it doesn't.
BRADY FORREST: I mean,
one of the reasons
I wanted to do the
show is because you
read a lot about
funding announcements,
and I think people
outside Silicon Valley
think that's all
that happens here.
But it's actually a
lot of long nights.
It's a lot of friendships.
It's a lot of really
trying to create something.
And that's what I want to show,
and that's what I'm hoping
is shown.
DAVE MCCLURE: And I
think, also, there's
a lot of people who have the
misconception that everything
turns out to be Facebook,
or Snapchat, or Google.
And actually, most shit fails.
BRADY FORREST: Yeah.
DAVE MCCLURE: I think
fortunately in our programs,
at least they have
some survivability
for a year or two.
And the majority of companies
do raise enough money
to have at least a shot at
becoming something interesting.
DANA HAN-KLEIN:
Every once in awhile
you get a wildfire, maybe.
DAVE MCCLURE: We
do occasionally.
DANA HAN-KLEIN: Which
we've heard of here.
No, I think there's
definitely sort
of a glamour associated with
the kind of startup culture
that we feel here.
And a lot of people
are afraid of revealing
the tough parts of it and the
struggle that goes into it.
And do you think this
is going to open up
that conversation,
between both the people
who are trying to enter
into these fields,
and the people who aren't
as familiar with it?
BRADY FORREST: I think it'll
give them a good feel for what
the pressure is like.
I mean, you're
working with people,
when you don't have much money.
Some cases, you're just
getting to know them,
and you're trying
to create something.
And just the pressure
they're under
is pretty unimaginable, if
you're not in there with them.
DAVE MCCLURE: I
think maybe there's
been some other treatments on
different shows in the past,
maybe some other ones that
are more recent, where it's
a little bit more
fanciful, and it's
maybe not what exactly
happens-- a little bit too
much of either nightclubs
in San Francisco,
or people just like coding.
And that's certainly part of it.
But I think trying to present
that people are getting
ready to pitch to
investors, how they figure
whether the product is
working, whether people
like the product.
Figuring out how to grow a
small business into a larger
business.
BRADY FORREST: And also,
I mean, these people
have been working on
it for months or years
before coming to us.
And they keep going well beyond.
We just brought in a company
that's raised about $400,000,
and they've been
around for two years.
And they're deployed in 270
homes around California.
And now, they're
trying to figure out
how to do mass production
and figure out if they
can raise additional funds.
But they're just with
us for four months.
DAVE MCCLURE: But
I think also, you
know, there is somewhat a
little bit of the American dream
writ in the geek fashion,
where people bust their ass,
occasionally raise
a million dollars,
and occasionally create a
company that's worth something
and hopefully grows
on to become larger.
And that is a pretty
compelling story,
and we hope to
have some of that.
DANA HAN-KLEIN: Yeah, I don't
think that's just limited
to the tech industry, you know?
I think that's what
drives industry.
So as you said, a
lot of these groups
are working with these
projects for a really long time
before they even get to you.
And sometimes, companies
and groups of working people
need to make really
tough decisions.
Maybe in terms of
changing direction,
maybe in terms of like,
hey, this isn't working.
What do you say to
people like that,
when you have to be like, hey,
it's time to change course?
BRADY FORREST: It all
depends on their resources.
It depends on the team.
It depends on whether we
still have faith in them.
DAVE MCCLURE: Yeah.
BRADY FORREST: Other investors.
DAVE MCCLURE: I would say mostly
it depends on the founders.
I mean, we're not
driving their companies
or running their companies.
They are.
I think, as investors,
at least for us, probably
both of our programs,
we're minority investors
in the company.
We're not taking board seats.
We're not making their
decisions about where to go.
We can give them feedback.
And often, that might be very
harsh and strong feedback.
But I think, for us, a
lot of it is really just,
is the product working?
Do customers want to buy it?
Are they making money?
Do they have a shot
at making money?
And can they grow?
BRADY FORREST: Is your go
to market strategy right?
Are you setting
yourself up to fail?
I'm doing with a
company right now that
just joined the
program, and they
want to launch
crowdfunding next month.
They don't know their
manufacturing plan.
They don't know exactly
who their customers are.
And I'm trying to
pull them back.
Like, you only get to
go to crowdfunding once.
You only get one first date.
Don't screw it up.
Make sure you're
prepared for it.
DANA HAN-KLEIN: Show up
showered in a nice car.
BRADY FORREST: Yeah.
DANA HAN-KLEIN: Brush
your teeth beforehand,
all that good stuff.
DAVE MCCLURE: Some people have
different ideas of what works.
I think giving people a
reality check on what can work
and what can't work is helpful.
And sometimes, that's
the other companies
in the accelerator
or previous companies
that have gone
through the program.
Sometimes it's us.
Sometimes we're wrong, too.
I think we're
looking for founders
who are a little bit
crazy, but not too crazy.
And there's kind
of a fine line--
DANA HAN-KLEIN: Passion.
You want passion.
DAVE MCCLURE: --between
genius and insanity
that we try and ride.
But you want people who are
going to take risks, just not
stupid risks.
DANA HAN-KLEIN:
What would you say
is-- maybe it's needing to
slow your role a little bit
and being like, hey, let's not
go to crowdfunding right away.
What are some of the
kind of rookie mistakes
that you do see, that you wish
you could just tell people
like, take a step back and
address these things before you
even possibly go to
these next stages?
BRADY FORREST: I mean,
on the hardware front,
it's assuming that you'll be
able to finish manufacturing
in six months.
Company formation
front, it's not
knowing who you're
founding the company with.
DAVE MCCLURE: I think that's
a big one, is really getting
to know your co-founders well.
A lot of times,
we tend to prefer
people who have worked
together before, at least
for 6 to 12 months,
if not longer.
There's a lot of things where
we're really-- unfortunately,
I don't think it's like people
going to market too quickly
is usually the problem.
Usually it's the
opposite problem-- people
waiting too long to ship or
not getting customer feedback
early enough.
Sometimes it's being overly
optimistic about funding.
I think people, even
people who come out
here who are familiar
with what goes on,
maybe are overly optimistic
about how easy it
is to raise a million bucks.
DANA HAN-KLEIN: You probably
hear a lot about like,
oh, well, whoever made it.
Yeah, but different sets of
circumstances, different people
involved.
BRADY FORREST: Yeah.
DAVE MCCLURE: But I mean,
there's a lot of things
that I think maybe 10 or
15 years ago used to be
much harder to figure out.
And we can probably help them
compress that now into maybe
six months to a year.
I think just the amount
of resources and access
that are available, both
online and in Silicon Valley,
and through investor platforms
like AngelList and others--
it's dramatically
easier, in my opinion,
to get a company
off the ground now.
It used to be,
15-20 years ago, you
had to know a certain
set of people.
You really needed
to figure out what
was going on without having
access to a bunch of user
groups or online forums.
DAVE MCCLURE: You had
to get your own servers.
DAVE MCCLURE: Yes.
BRADY FORREST: And now
it's a credit card.
DAVE MCCLURE: Pay Oracle
a couple million dollars
for database software, and
Sun a couple million dollars
for some hardware, and
maybe companies like Exodus,
which probably no
one remembers here,
that used to host servers.
BRADY FORREST: I remember
MongoMusic in 2000.
We had Oracle.
DAVE MCCLURE: It's
so easy these days!
Kids my day used to walk
up hill both ways to school
before they launched
any commerce project.
So yeah, I think
there's a lot of things
that are still far from
perfect with the startup world.
But there are a
lot of things which
are much faster and easier,
and hopefully we're helpful.
DANA HAN-KLEIN: Great.
Let's talk briefly
about pitching,
because you seem to be very
passionate about the way people
pitch things and
trying to get people
to come out of their shells.
And it's a hugely important
part of any presentation.
DAVE MCCLURE: Yes.
DANA HAN-KLEIN: A lot
of this is being like,
give me a lot of money
please for this idea
that may or may not work.
DAVE MCCLURE: That sounds
like a great pitch.
You should come over
and [INAUDIBLE].
DANA HAN-KLEIN: Yeah.
That's my elevator pitch you--
give me a lot of money, please.
But it's a hugely
important part.
Can you talk about, one, some of
the challenges of maybe getting
people who are behind
the scenes people
to have to be in front
of large audiences
in a very high stakes scenario?
BRADY FORREST: It's
hours on stage.
You have to put
yourself out there.
And a lot of people, they've
never done it before,
and it just takes time.
They just have to keep doing
it, and doing it, and doing it.
DAVE MCCLURE: I think
there's a lot of folks
who come from an engineering
and/or nerdy background who are
not used to public speaking.
And strangely, I used to be
one of those persons-- people.
I was deathly afraid of public
speaking probably 20 years ago,
I guess.
And most of my training
was not on stage.
It was mostly
engineering background.
Although I was bit of a drama
theatre geek in high school.
But I think the thing
is most folks get
far too into the weeds.
Or they want to be Steve
Jobs and tell this very long
and elaborate story.
And we do want a little bit of
magic in what they're saying.
But primarily, we
try to coach people
to really focus on
the numbers, if they
have some amount of
traction, is what we call it.
So whether they've
got a product,
got customers, got users,
got revenue, got funding.
Those are all different
measures of traction.
And so a lot of the pitch
that we try and teach people
is really what we call kind
of a traction sandwich.
We're like, here's the numbers.
Establish some
credibility quickly, then
tell the customer
problem framework story.
Here's the customer's problem.
Here's our solution
to that problem.
Here's some proof
that that works.
And then finish up with traction
and get the hell off stage.
Try and do that quickly
and clearly first.
A lot of people want
to be entertaining
while they're doing that.
That's the next level.
But first level is
just be fucking clear.
Try and be concise and brief.
And then, if you can work in
some entertainment in there
after you accomplish
those goals, that's great.
BRADY FORREST: And your
pitches are two minutes long?
DAVE MCCLURE: Three minutes,
although we encourage people
to take less time as possible.
They hardly ever
take that advice.
BRADY FORREST: So ours is four,
but we usually work in a demo,
because it's hardware.
And we would do
less if we could.
DAVE MCCLURE: Pretty
much you're winning
the customer or the
audience attention
within the first
30 seconds or not.
And if you aren't
sexy or interesting
the first 30 seconds,
it's unlikely you're
going to get a lot more sexy or
interesting in the next three
to five minutes or longer.
So sometimes,
usually less is more.
DANA HAN-KLEIN:
Absolutely, yeah.
So not everyone is lucky enough
to get advice from you guys
directly.
DAVE MCCLURE: Yes.
We're so fucking important.
DANA HAN-KLEIN: But
they're probably
getting a lot of advice
from other sources.
And what would you say-- and
sometimes it's really tough.
It's maybe somebody
who's close to you.
It's family sometimes.
It's friends you've worked
with for a long time.
But that doesn't always
mean it's good advice.
So what do you guys feel about
trusting yourself and doing
a gut check versus
taking feedback
from these other sources?
DAVE MCCLURE: Oh, our advice
isn't always correct, either.
BRADY FORREST: Ultimately,
it's your company.
It's your product.
And so even when I'm
talking with companies about
whether or not they
should do crowdfunding,
ultimately they have to
live with the decision.
They know their bank accounts.
They know their risk tolerance.
But the number one thing they
shouldn't lie to themselves
about is what the
customers want.
And so getting the
product in the hands
of your potential users, that's
stuff that you can't ignore.
DAVE MCCLURE: I think
both the feedback
from other entrepreneurs
who've done some of the things
before is important, as well as
getting feedback of customers
who are using your product.
And we still depend a lot of
the entrepreneur's intuition
about what they
want to do, where
they feel the product can go.
But you probably
shouldn't ignore
people who've gone through
that process a couple times.
And you shouldn't ignore the
people who are buying or using
your product.
BRADY FORREST: Yeah, there's
actually a great book
by my friend Dan Shapiro
called "The Hot Seat," which
is about his experiences
as like a five-time CEO.
There's just like 45
different vignettes about it.
And he was an
ex-Googler, as well.
DANA HAN-KLEIN: That actually
leads me to another question.
What are some of the
inspiration sources,
aside from maybe people who have
through this process before,
that you do send your folks to?
Either books or speakers
in real life, or--
BRADY FORREST: We gave
everyone at Highway1,
this class, "The Hot
Seat," which is his book.
And then we brought in--
we bring in Eric Ries
to speak, "The Lean Startup."
DAVE MCCLURE: Eric Ries, who
is the author of "The Lean
Startup."
Yeah, I think, you
know, there's a lot
of folks who are
very knowledgeable.
And some of them,
if not many of them,
have started companies before.
But most of the feedback
that I think is more valuable
is coming from other
founders, some of whom
haven't been around
the block that long
and aren't necessarily
household names,
but have been through those
experiences more recently.
We do fireside chats with some
of our founders, a few of whom
have actually started
companies or exited companies,
raised 10s if not
100s of millions.
And a few of them have hired or
acquired thousands of people.
But a lot of times,
hearing the stories
from other folks who
are maybe still running
10-person companies or
20-person companies who
just went through it
a year or two earlier,
it somehow maybe seems a
little bit more authentic.
BRADY FORREST: Yeah, we really
try and connect our cohorts
together.
So the first week, we do
a Bay Area factory tour
so that they're stuck on a bus
getting to know each other.
And we take them
to China so they
can see Chinese manufacturing.
And they really bond
during that trip.
DAVE MCCLURE: Sometimes we
take them over here, actually.
We do field trips to Google,
and Facebook, and YouTube,
and other companies
in the Bay Area
that are a little bit
larger than our startups.
And some of that's really to get
to know the different product
groups and things
that are going on.
Sometimes it's just
to get to know people
in the companies who've been
through the process before.
DANA HAN-KLEIN: Great.
I think the show
sounds like it's also
going to be a great way to
kind of open up that process
and save maybe you guys a little
bit of the time on being like,
look, these are the people who
have gone through it before.
But what's one thing--
DAVE MCCLURE: Sometimes
learning from failure also
can be helpful.
DANA HAN-KLEIN: It's
an important process.
It's true.
Like you absolutely
sometimes need
to fail in order to know
what it is to succeed.
And what's one thing you
hope that people take away
from being able to see this
in-depth into this process?
BRADY FORREST: That
it's a lot of work,
but that it can be a lot of fun.
DAVE MCCLURE: I think hopefully
buying the bottle-head dolls
with our heads on them.
Merchandising!
BRADY FORREST: We get more
margin on the t-shirts.
DAVE MCCLURE: Oh, OK.
BRADY FORREST: T-shirts.
DAVE MCCLURE: I
think, you know, it's
really a chance to tell
the story of Silicon
Valley a little bit more
upfront and in-person.
Again, you can watch movies
like "The Social Network"
or read books about
Google or Amazon founders.
And there's a piece of that
world which is probably real.
I used to work for Sean Parker.
I do know some of those stories.
I know a lot of folks
who have founded
companies in the valley.
But I think also just
really getting a chance
to see-- I won't
say normal people,
but geeky individuals that you
might meet in real life, who
face all the struggles
of starting a company,
learning how to be a leader,
or sometimes not measuring up
to that expectation.
BRADY FORREST: I
think also, we have
all different
types of people who
are starting companies in this.
We had a Dutch team.
We had a team that's super
passionate about aquariums
and just decided
to dive into tech.
Where are some of
your teams from?
DAVE MCCLURE: We have a lot of
folks from all over the world.
Actually, probably
close to half,
sometimes even more than
half of our companies,
are from outside the US.
And hopefully,
they're not always
as white and male as some
of Silicon Valley is.
I think that's still a
challenge we all face.
But at least maybe a
little bit more female,
non-white and not quite--
DANA HAN-KLEIN: I
wouldn't mind seeing that.
DAVE MCCLURE: Yeah.
So we'll see.
DANA HAN-KLEIN: We are
in a very diverse world.
It's no longer just
Silicon Valley.
It's China.
It's all these other companies.
There are different people on
the map who have great ideas
and are-- so it's great to
see that being represented
and working on
being represented.
DAVE MCCLURE: I mean, I think
it's a big focus for us.
We've been investing outside
the US for the last five years.
We have probably done
investments in over 50
countries and have about 300
companies out of the portfolio
that didn't start in the US.
It's not to say it's still not
a little bit more white and male
than maybe we would prefer.
And I'm not always the poster
child for diversity efforts,
but I'm trying.
We have a lot of other
folks on our team
who do represent
different walks of life.
DANA HAN-KLEIN: I think being
aware of the problem and trying
is definitely the first step.
Can you guys think
of a startup that you
felt was maybe going to be
a big gamble that you went,
you know what, we're going
for it, and that paid off?
BRADY FORREST: Huh.
DAVE MCCLURE: Uh--
DANA HAN-KLEIN: Or not.
DAVE MCCLURE: I think almost
every startup I invested in.
BRADY FORREST: Yeah.
Actually, one company from
our first batch-- Queue--
was at-home medical diagnostics.
And you could test to see if you
have the flu or inflammation.
And I just didn't believe
them that it would--
I was like, that's
Jetsons stuff.
How are they able to do that?
And some doctor friends
were like, no, no, no, they
could do that.
It's really hard,
but they could do it.
And so they've done pretty well.
DAVE MCCLURE: I think
probably one of ours,
it's one of the
more fun stories.
We invested in a
company called Maven
that was started by a black
founder who-- I think he's also
black and Jewish
and speaks Mandarin,
but that's kind of
besides the point.
But the company was
basically powering e-commerce
for beauty sites,
beauticians that
focus on the African
American beauty market,
basically hair weaves
and a lot of other stuff.
And that company's
done fabulously well.
They just raised
over $10 million
from Andreessen Horowitz.
Although, the first two
years weren't quite as easy.
I think when we first
invested in the company,
my partner Christine and I
were eager to try that out,
but we obviously both weren't--
neither of us were customers.
But I think it was
the kind of story
that we felt like was an
underrepresented market.
And we weren't doing
it out of charity,
we were doing it out of--
DANA HAN-KLEIN: Oh,
it's a huge market.
DAVE MCCLURE: --greed
to some extent.
And it's really been great to
see that company totally kick
ass and now is employing
over 50 people in Oakland
and doing-- I won't
share all the numbers,
but I think 10s of millions--
we'll see-- in revenue.
So that's maybe a very
non-traditional Silicon Valley
story.
DANA HAN KLEIN:
Yeah, absolutely.
We're going to throw it to
audience questions in a moment,
but I wanted to know,
what's an area of tech
that you guys are excited
to see more development in?
You've mentioned
medical is definitely
an emerging more home market.
DAVE MCCLURE: I think Brady's
got the more sci-fi sort
of esque stories to tell here.
BRADY FORREST: You know,
I like wearing my Fitbit.
But it doesn't actually do
anything for me right now.
I want things to
give me superpowers.
Yeah, so we have a
company with us right now
that actually improves
recovery time from athletics.
And you can picture these-- it's
like currently $1,000 machines
that they have for
football players.
And these would
be $100 stockings
that you could
wear while skiing.
And then when
you're on the lift,
it will help pump the blood up
and help you recover faster.
And you could wear it on planes.
Stuff like that.
That's the type of
thing I'm looking for.
DAVE MCCLURE: It sounds
like pantyhose for seniors.
I might need that.
BRADY FORREST: You are-- I mean,
you just have the marketing
thing down for me.
DAVE MCCLURE: Yeah.
I could [INAUDIBLE].
DANA HAN-KLEIN: Sold.
DAVE MCCLURE: I
think we tend to work
on stuff that's a little
less sexy than the space age
[INAUDIBLE].
DANA HAN-KLEIN:
Pantyhose for seniors?
DAVE MCCLURE: Yeah, exactly.
BRADY FORREST: Huge market.
DAVE MCCLURE: A lot of
things that we focus on
tend to be very straightforward
e-commerce and SaaS
and marketplace stories.
But those are happening in
a lot of interesting places
now for us.
So sometimes it's
more about where we're
doing that work than what.
And so getting to see
e-commerce in Africa,
or SaaS in India
or Southeast Asia
is actually pretty exciting
and hopefully also makes us
some money.
DANA HAN-KLEIN:
And since this is
sci-fi, what is one
future technology
that you'd like to see
realized in our lifetime?
The replicator from Star
Trek or phasers, or--?
DAVE MCCLURE: Wormholes.
Teleportation.
More sleep.
Can I get an extra
two hours a day?
BRADY FORREST: Oh, that
would be really nice.
DANA HAN-KLEIN: That
would be really nice,
I think for everyone here.
We'd all love that.
DAVE MCCLURE: Tribbles.
DANA HAN-KLEIN: There's
some trouble with those.
DAVE MCCLURE: Yeah.
Wow.
DANA HAN-KLEIN: I work
at a nerdy company too.
Don't worry.
And finally, we see plenty
of startups be successful.
What's one thing that you truly
think differentiates a rock
star startup?
You can say advice from you two.
Being in your accelerators.
DAVE MCCLURE: You know, I
hate to say basic things
like customers, but that's
probably where it comes from.
I think a little bit of
insanity is probably necessary.
People who don't always
listen to what you say.
As much as it's
like, we're supposed
to be nerd whispers
and helping people
figure out their startups,
a lot of times the best
entrepreneurs are the ones
who don't listen to us
and who teach us things.
BRADY FORREST: Yeah.
I definitely want people
who are willing to carry
through and get things done.
So much of a startup
is just about execution
and actually doing what they
say they're going to do.
DANA HAN-KLEIN: Thank you.
Do we have any questions
from the audience?
AUDIENCE: --talk
a little bit more
about the motivation
and strategy
for getting involved at
this stage of investing.
So it's like seed
stage, early stage.
Especially given you
take minority stakes,
and you don't have as
much skin in the game.
So what's the
motivation behind that?
DAVE MCCLURE: It's
probably a labor of love
more than anything else.
The question was, why do
we get involved so early
when companies are
more likely to fail?
We don't have
minority ownership,
and basically we have absolutely
no control over how it goes.
I mean, one thing is the
companies are less expensive.
So when we're investing
at an early stage,
valuations are low.
Also, it's less
competitive to get
into those companies
in many cases
than when they raise capital
from other larger folks,
if they're more successful.
BRADY FORREST: And if we're
structuring our programs right,
we increase the value
of the companies
in a very short amount of time.
DAVE MCCLURE: I
think we're generally
trying to focus on companies
that have challenges
around product-market
fit and early customer
acquisition and growth.
So working around
product and marketing
are areas that we tend
to focus on a lot.
As companies get
much larger, things
start to change into real
more organizational scale
and operationalizing
a lot of process.
And frankly, those are
kind of fucking boring,
and I don't want to do that.
So it's a lot more interesting
to work with people when
teams are small, stakes
are frankly higher,
and we can build a
relationship with them
and really hopefully
be impactful
around the product vision and
around the initial customer
acquisition.
But I guess it's really kind of
more what people's appetite are
for what stage of the process
they want to be active in.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
BRADY FORREST:
One of the reasons
that I started Highway1
is to help bring things
into the world that
otherwise wouldn't happen.
There aren't that many
resources for hardware startups.
And hardware startups
can get hurt really
easily by bad decisions.
So going to
manufacturing too early
or not having good partners,
not knowing how to model out
the revenue or their inventory.
So that's what we try
and teach them how to do.
AUDIENCE: Hey.
So I've got a lot of good advice
from Brady over the years,
but startups get so much advice
from so many different people,
and so much of it
is contradictory.
DAVE MCCLURE: No it's not.
BRADY FORREST: Yes, it is.
DAVE MCCLURE: No, it's not.
AUDIENCE: What advice
about advice do you have?
BRADY FORREST: [LAUGHS]
DAVE MCCLURE:
That's kind of meta.
BRADY FORREST: Listen, but
then decide on your own.
DAVE MCCLURE: I
think the idea is
that you want to get feedback
from different sources
and at least hear a
range of opinions.
I would say I do tend to take
feedback more thoughtfully
from people who've done
similar things before,
either on the investor
or the entrepreneur side.
Again, a lot of that
feedback doesn't necessarily
come from us.
It comes from other
entrepreneurs.
But yeah, you're going
to get a lot of opinions.
Opinions are like assholes.
Everybody's got one.
They all smell bad.
It's up to you to figure
out which of those you
want to take to heart.
AUDIENCE: What is the
profile or characteristic
of a group of a project, or
already a formed company, that
should go into accelerator?
What companies or projects
should not go into accelerator?
DAVE MCCLURE: Depends
on the accelerator
and depends on the company.
But do you want to
talk about yours?
BRADY FORREST: Yeah.
I mean, we look for
companies that are
looking to be venture backed.
So if you're not
interested in taking VC,
then Highway1 is probably not
the right program for you.
And I would think that's true
with a lot of accelerators.
And in our case, we focus
exclusively on hardware.
So if you're not doing
hardware-- and we
end up getting applications
for software companies.
But we look for teams
that have a prototype, two
to four people.
Hopefully, they've raised a
couple hundred thousand hours.
They're past Arduino,
but they've shared it out
to their customers.
They've done some
customer validation.
And we'll take them from there.
And then those first
weeks, we introduce them
to designers,
industrial design firms,
and start to move them
towards a looks like,
works like prototype.
And that's our general MO.
And then, after they leave us,
they head to manufacturing.
So it's kind of a company
that's on the cusp of having
their final product.
DAVE MCCLURE: I
think, for us, we
tend to focus on
companies that have
a specific stage of product
development and early customer
acquisition where we can be
helpful in scaling that up.
So we're generally not
looking for companies
that are only concepts and
not even just functional
prototype, but
probably, if they're
revenue generating,
maybe $5,000 to $25,000
a month, between maybe
$50,000 to $100,000 a year.
And in some cases,
more than that.
But the emphasis we're
going to try and do
is, can we figure out ways to
be helpful in scaling customer
channels by 10x,
if that's possible?
Emphasis tends to be on
online customer acquisition.
So how do we use paid and
organic platforms, search,
social, mobile, video, local?
A lot of efforts tend
to look at maybe Google
for paid organic
search, Facebook
and Twitter for social,
Apple and Android for mobile.
Other things we're
looking at now
are probably YouTube,
Pinterest, Instagram.
But even other platforms that
are just text and messaging.
I think we've been looking a lot
like WeChat, WhatsApp, Facebook
Messenger, other
messaging platforms as now
an initial platform for growth.
So a lot of what we want to
see is early customer usage
and revenue, but not so much
that the company's already
off to the races and scaling.
And then trying to
help them figure out
online customer acquisition
techniques, not just
product development.
So it's a big issue
with a lot of companies,
not limited to just
Silicon Valley.
It's going to build feature,
feature, feature all day long.
And then, oh, marketing
will happen later,
and our product will be
so amazing that everybody
will just tell
everybody, and it'll all
work based on viral
growth and word of mouth.
And that's usually bullshit, And
the product marketing concepts
and campaigns are as much a
part of the product as anything.
AUDIENCE: So actually, to follow
up pretty much what you just
said there, I work with a lot
of startups that come to Google
and are looking-- they're
usually Post Series A, a lot
B2B and Saas, and may not
have had some of the advice
that you've been trying to
pass on about growth marketing
strategy being an early
part of your focus
and trying to make that an
organic part of your growth
pattern.
So we get a lot
of post Series A.
They bring on five
new people who
are going to be hired through
acquisition, who might not have
been part of the founding
team, and have all of a sudden
these huge scaling goals in
order to meet what they've
promised their investors.
And in many ways, they want
us to do that for them.
What advice do you have
for those companies that
have not already started to
get the groundwork lead earlier
in the process,
but are already now
at the point of trying to prove
themselves with a little bit
less experience coming in
than we may have hoped for?
DAVE MCCLURE: Probably
take a few classes
in human psychology,
I would say.
Strangely, how much
money someone has raised
is not often correlated
with how far along they
are in their customer
acquisition strategies.
And a lot of people
tend to think
they can just buy growth
later, whether that's
through hires or throwing money
at paid acquisition platforms.
I think, fundamentally,
we want people
to look at what's the initial
activation and retention
cycle what their customers?
And is that working?
And to really dig
in on that first.
Trying to force a lot of
users through a leaky bucket
is not going to be an
excellent strategy,
if that's very expensive.
So the first thing we're
really trying to understand
is do people use the product,
and do they come back?
And do they tell other people?
Or at least, do they
have a positive opinion
of the product?
And then starting to look
at channels for growth,
if that first set of activation
and retention test is met.
But I think the hack
that we're really
trying to bring
to a lot of people
is the fact that--
everybody thinks
technology platforms is
what's changed in the last 10,
15, 20 years.
And indeed, that's true.
Prices have come down.
And things are less expensive.
But the really dramatic change
that actually has happened
is around human behavior
and social behavior
and communication.
And that people have
dramatically shifted behaviors
from television, print, and
radio to online platforms.
And that that's a
really interesting way
to expose them to new
products and services,
and for them to
learn about stuff.
And we really are not
very good at figuring out
how to do marketing
on those platforms.
And for a lot of
geeks, that sounds
like an unnecessary evil.
They really-- oh,
salespeople are bad.
That's how I used to think.
I was a programmer.
And I was like,
oh, salespeople are
a necessary evil I tolerate
to maybe get customers
and raise money.
But otherwise, they're
scum sucking dirt bags,
and I really don't want to
have anything to do with them.
And now, I'm in sales.
Like, oh, well, there are
some redeeming qualities.
But I think the idea is around
understanding that there's
a world of customers
out there that
are reachable to you via some
amount of calculated marketing
techniques.
It's not to say that
things aren't still
going to be creative.
But there are billions of
peoples on all those platforms,
and some of them
are from Google.
Some of them are from Facebook.
Some of them from Tencent
and Baidu and Alibaba.
And kind of learning what
that world is all about,
and how we interact
with them, is a skill
set that I think most Silicon
Valley engineers and founders
still don't understand well.
DANA HAN-KLEIN: Thanks.
Over here.
AUDIENCE: So in a way, I follow
up to this last question.
Yesterday, I was at a
bookstore in Mountain View.
I saw "Forbes" Magazine.
I think it was the
founder of Slack.
DAVE MCCLURE: [INAUDIBLE].
DANA HAN-KLEIN: And I think he
has a background in philosophy.
Sophie And the whole
piece of this month
was around the
increase in importance
in non-technical
founders in the Valley.
I think, at least
as far as I know,
everything that I had
in mind was always,
oh, you know, these
MBAs that just
want the technical
guys to build the stuff
and who don't understand
really what's going on.
DAVE MCCLURE: MBAs
aren't inherently evil.
They're just drawn that way.
AUDIENCE: Exactly.
So one thing, what's your view
on non-technical founders?
And what do you
look for in teams
that get to your accelerators
or want to work with you?
BRADY FORREST: I mean, Stewart's
been in technology for decades,
now.
Slack was not-- he didn't
just dream up Slack.
DAVE MCCLURE: He started this
other little company called
Flickr.
BRADY FORREST: Yeah, he started
a game call "Game Neverending."
That turned into Flickr.
Then he started another
game called "Glitch"
and that turned into Slack.
DAVE MCCLURE: Someday, he's
really going to prove himself.
BRADY FORREST: Yeah,
someday he'll figure it out.
DAVE MCCLURE: He's really
going to get that game thing.
[LAUGHTER]
BRADY FORREST:
But Stewart is a--
DAVE MCCLURE: Is
he a non-technical?
BRADY FORREST: He
must be technical.
Just because he has
a philosophy degree.
He must know how to program.
DAVE MCCLURE: I think.
BRADY FORREST: I
mean, he certainly
has partnered with [INAUDIBLE].
DAVE MCCLURE: You're saying just
because he has social skills,
he's nontechnical.
[LAUGHTER]
AUDIENCE: Maybe not
so much about-- this
was just an example.
But in general, not about
him, but in general,
what's your view about
non-technical founders.
BRADY FORREST: I'm pretty
sure he doing web consulting
before he started
Game Neverending.
DAVE MCCLURE: He's been probably
in the Valley-- well, sorry,
Vancouver and the
Valley, I guess.
BRADY FORREST: Yeah.
Vancouver, bouncing
back and forth.
DAVE MCCLURE: 15 years?
DANA HAN-KLEIN:
Canadian Valley, right?
BRADY FORREST: But
I think if you're
the person-- if you
are a clear thinker,
and you are able
to get things done,
to build a team,
then you don't need
to be technical.
You--
DAVE MCCLURE: Wait, what?
What?
BRADY FORREST: It's true.
You know, Kevin Rose
somewhat famously
paid a developer $5,000 to
build the first version of Digg
and then was able to raise
some funding based on that.
DAVE MCCLURE: Poland or
Eastern Europe somewhere.
BRADY FORREST: Yeah,
something like that.
DAVE MCCLURE: I think having
basic functional skills
in programming, and design,
and marketing are probably
goals for all of us.
Not just startup people,
but actually everyone.
BRADY FORREST: Being
able to write well.
DAVE MCCLURE: Yeah, really.
BRADY FORREST: Grammar.
DAVE MCCLURE: But
I think there's
this weird focus on
programming these days,
which I kind of think
people are missing the ball.
Everybody's like,
girls should code!
And I'm like, yes,
and-- my little girl, I
want to be running the fucking
company, not just coding.
So I have a little higher
aspirations for her
than just coding.
And so programming is
important, but there
tends to be this
thing in the Valley,
like the top of the food
chain is programming.
And I really think
that's kind of misplaced.
And I say that starting out as
someone who was a programmer
and programmed since 11 or 12.
I took my final in college high,
and got an A+, but whatever,
on programming.
There was a time at
which I was like,
OK, I'm good at programming,
and running a company
is not just about that.
As much as really amazing
programmers definitely
have an advantage, and
companies that have them
definitely have an advantage.
BRADY FORREST: But if
you're doing a tech startup,
you need to be tech literate.
And so I think that's
probably-- I mean,
that's what Stewart ended
up doing over the years,
is he probably taught
himself how to program.
DAVE MCCLURE: Design and
UX are really important.
Understanding marketing
concepts is really important,
whether those are
creative or quantitative.
And just learning how
to deal with people
and interacting with them
is pretty fucking important.
BRADY FORREST: Being able
to understand your customer.
DAVE MCCLURE: Yeah.
So it's a little bit more
holistic than just coding.
AUDIENCE: And what do
you look at in teams that
apply for the accelerators?
DAVE MCCLURE: For us, primarily
product and customers.
I think we want to
look at the product,
and see how it
works and operates,
and we want to understand
customer reactions to product.
BRADY FORREST:
And in our case, I
want to see that they've
actually built something,
that they've been
working on this,
and that they have the
skills to carry it forward.
DAVE MCCLURE: I think
everybody talks about team
all fucking day long.
And yes, team is the
most important thing.
Except your ability
to tell like what
that team's all about
in three or four
meetings over the case of a
couple weeks is pretty limited.
So unless you've actually
done extensive due diligence
over periods of
months, if not years,
it's going to be hard for you to
understand whether that team is
amazing or not.
So one of the reasons
we really want
to see founders
have worked together
is at least they've assured
themselves that they're not--
the other person isn't crazy.
And then we want to look at
maybe some historical work
that they've done.
Could be at a company, or could
be at a school or something.
But probably the most
important thing is like,
what's my direct experience
of their product?
And what's the customer's
experience of that product?
And are KPIs moving in
the right direction?
It's really easy for people
to make gut decisions about
whether they think teams
are amazing or not.
And I think that probably ends
up being why a lot of teams
are white and male, is because
most of the people making
decisions are white and male,
and it's a little easier
for them to make
those gut decisions
when there are things
that are familiar to them.
You miss a lot of great
opportunities if you do that.
Not to say that there
aren't very talented
white and male founders.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
I have a question for David.
I think I remember from
one of your talks is
that your inspiration
to have 500 Startups
is you have lots of data points
to improve your decision making
into which company
to investing in.
Right?
DAVE MCCLURE: The goal was
not to have 500 Startups,
although that was the
name of the company.
It was simply to
choose a lot of them.
But I think a lot of our
philosophy about investing
is basically that we are not
always great stock pickers.
But if we have a larger
portfolio, we'll find success.
AUDIENCE: I see.
So my question is, is your
decision making improved over
the years or not?
DAVE MCCLURE: I have
no fucking idea.
DANA HAN-KLEIN: Say yes.
AUDIENCE: Is [INAUDIBLE] of
fund two better than fund one?
DAVE MCCLURE: Yes.
That is true.
Probably by at least 500
basis points, I think.
I'd say that one isn't bad.
One's performed
pretty good, too.
But I'm not investing in
all the companies anymore.
We have about 20-- we have
75 people in the company.
About 20 of those are
making investment decisions.
And our goal is really to
scale the investing process
so that many people are
making many decisions globally
all the time.
And 500 is actually a
relatively small number
for what we're
eventually aiming for.
I think there's-- strangely,
the venture capital industry,
as much as it's all about
scale and technology,
is pretty hypocritical and
hasn't done either of those
things well itself.
And the largest
VC funds right now
probably aren't much
more than 100 people.
Most of them are
far less than that.
So scaling the
organization globally,
and doing thousands, if not 10s
of thousands of investments,
and eventually 100s of
thousands, or possibly
millions, is our goal.
That may sound fucking crazy.
But I think building a startup
with 500 to 1,000 people
seems sort of
pedestrian, almost small.
To think of a VC fund that
has 500 to 1,000 people
seems wacky.
But there's a lot
of innovation left
to do in the venture industry.
AUDIENCE: I think
Benchmark has six, I think.
DAVE MCCLURE: Yeah.
They're so small.
Gosh.
Well, except in height.
Bill's pretty tall.
DANA HAN-KLEIN: I think we
have time for one more audience
question.
AUDIENCE: You talked a bit
about execution failures.
What do those look like?
Is that people running
out of stamina?
DAVE MCCLURE: When we
fail to kill people.
That's execution failure.
[LAUGHTER]
BRADY FORREST: I mean,
for a Highway1 team,
it's often a poor technology
decision that they then
just waste a lot of time on.
Or wasting time on the
wrong person pitching, when
that person's not
delivering, and they need
someone else, or a bad hire.
It's often a decision that
routes them and wastes
their time.
DAVE MCCLURE: There's just
a ton of different ways
to fuck up a startup.
And most of those involve
not delivering product
for customers, but
there's also hiring fail.
There's developing a product
that people love but you're not
making enough money about.
Or there's not being able to
scale that to larger audiences.
So it's hard to sort of say
there's one or very specific
things.
There's just lots and
lots of different ways.
BRADY FORREST: But
we inevitably--
we just started this
next batch, but we'll
have two or three founders
leave during the program.
That's the most common fail case
that we see within the program.
DANA HAN-KLEIN: On that
very positive note--
BRADY FORREST: Sorry!
DANA HAN-KLEIN: No, but
sometimes it's necessary.
And if it's not right for you
guys, it's not right for them.
Why continue on that path?
But with that, thank you so
much for joining us today.
And let's give a
round of applause.
[APPLAUSE]